now one of the reasons that many people
seem to have this kind of love and
reverence for nature is that it somehow
represents something that is authentic
we're often given this idea that our
regular lives which will often involve
living in the city having jobs and
participating in consumerism that these
things are somehow inauthentic that this
is an unnatural way to live
at Nature by contrast is often defined
as the very opposite of all these things
nature is beyond the influence of humans
and all these societal structures nature
is more real somehow more authentic it
represents something primordial before
the influence of all these inauthentic
aspects of our regular lives
and because nature is real and authentic
this means that humans can use it as a
kind of as a kind of mirror